you
[Music]
so my name is mark sellers I'm head of
data engineering for a consulting
company in the UK called mango solutions
we do a lot of kind of production our
deployments and things like that and
what I'm going to talk to you today is
actually a slight change of gear I think
from some of the stuff that we've heard
so far so what I'm not going to talk
about is a one weird trick that we use
to get our and product into production
and I'm also not going to talk
specifically about any code that might
help you run our in production that's
not really the area that I work in so
where I work a lot of the time we're
helping organizations adopt the our
language and trying to help businesses
of varying sizes up you know from very
small organizations up to massive
government agencies to adopt the
language in their businesses which isn't
always an easy conversation to have and
so this is kind of my starting point and
I think I genuinely think that all of
the technical barriers to running are in
production are easy to overcome I say
easy I mean comparatively easy right
those are always challenges but it's the
cultural barriers that slow us down so
there's some overlap here with what Joe
Chang was talking about this morning
and I like to present this as a kind of
inspirational quote but actually it was
just something I said on Twitter one
time and but I do genuinely believe it
so much like Joe who kind of you know
stealing my thunder this morning and we
need to start out with a working
definition of what production actually
means and and mines kind of similar to
Joe there's a lot of overlap but
basically and when people say production
they tend to sort of have this idea in
their head of what production means and
duction is the same as massive right
that's that's kind of the basis for all
these production kind of conversations
and when people historically have said
oh well you know you can't run are in
production quite often what they mean is
you can't run are at scale and even
that's not true anymore so these are a
I'm pretty sure I'm not 100% sure
because I stole the image from Google
but I think these are Google racks
actually in their data center and I
think they're Google's tensive
processing units but this is the kind of
thing that people think of when we talk
about production but actually production
and scale not the same thing at all so
for me production is anything that's run
repeatedly and that the business relies
on so hopefully I'm kind of lining up
with Joe Chang on that one and and the
important bits of that are that it's
repeated or continuous kind of an
extension of the same idea and that it's
relied upon now in most of the
organizations that I work with when
you're implementing are in production
the people that kind of target audience
for those our environments are anywhere
from 10 20 people up to a few hundred
people so those people will rely on the
information that's being presented to
them you know whether it's information
in a shiny application or whether
they're running R and a HPC cluster or
something like that they're they're
actually relying on that information
that they're getting back to it to kind
of inform decision-making within the
business or you know to bring a new drug
to market or whatever it may be
so actually R is great in production
there are a number of reasons for this
are doesn't have a lot of the baggage
that other programming languages do and
I'm thinking specifically things like
the Python 2 3 schism there's still an
awful lot of stuff in Python
which is slowing adoption of Python 3
and that's because it's you so heavily
on Linux systems that where vendors are
perhaps a little slower to upgrade
things and obviously are doesn't have
that baggage so you can install whatever
version or versions of our you want to
use and and I found overall that
performance is exceptional on top of
that you obviously got fantastic package
ecosystem and things like that that we
can draw on to build great things like
we saw from the previous talk and so
what I really want to talk about is
actually how we get there how do we get
our into production so maybe you're
working at an organization now you could
perhaps got are on your desktop
something like that but you're not
running anything are based in production
and there are traditionally a number of
number of reasons for this and they
mostly revolve around the way that
businesses have evolved in terms of
their kind of technology adoption and so
what we've found when we look at the
when we look at the market and when we
talk to our customers and things like
that is that there is interest in
adopting new technologies and bringing
new things into the business but they're
perhaps not sure how to go about it so
this tension I guess a lot of people
will look at their business and say well
IT won't let me run our in production
but actually often it's not IT it's the
business as a whole which is obviously
what informs IT and kind of provides all
the kind of basis for their security
infrastructure and the network
infrastructure and all that sort of
thing so there are two kind of distinct
approaches that have emerged in the work
that I've done and the businesses that
we've talked to over the last so I've
been doing this sort of work for about
six years and there are there are two
paths that I've seen people be really
successful
for getting our into their organizations
and I want to talk a little bit about
those now so the left-hand path is the
path of magic essentially so if you
think about the great talk that we saw a
moment ago and part of what happened was
that a fantastic shiny app was presented
to somebody important and then that
drove the kind of decision making over
whether to use our or something like
that
downwards in the organization so the
path of magic is a great path it's a
short can be a very short path but if
you're also sort of fraught with
difficulty I guess because what can
happen is it can backfire a little bit
so this path I think is brilliant and
like I say can be a really good shortcut
and especially if you've got something
really powerful that you can demonstrate
but you can get kicked back later on
when we come to talk to IT teams about
actually getting that stuff into the
production ecosystem within the business
so that's one option and hopefully
that's kind of fairly easy to understand
the right-hand path though is so the
right-hand path has I guess I don't want
to say guarantees because there are
never any guarantees but what you're
looking for with the right-hand path is
for the business to have confidence in
the work that you're doing and
historically that's the area we're
getting are into production kind of
falls down so the IT team might look at
the work that a data scientist is doing
and go well I'm not confident in what
you're doing because where's the test
team you know where's your requirements
document and things like that all these
kind of historical software engineering
things that have been sort of adopted by
businesses over the last 50 60 years
whatever it may be
and so we need to kind of address that
elephant in the room
which is essentially to come to the
understanding and to sort of agree that
data science isn't software engineering
we know it isn't software engineering
and that's absolutely fine and in terms
of the kind of rigor that goes into
these different disciplines the rigor
goes into a different place in data
science and so what what I usually see
from data science teams is that they're
very good ensuring their code does what
they think it does that's obviously
extremely important and but also that
they're kind of methodologically sound I
guess and then data science will often
stop there software engineering on the
other hand obviously has a different set
of drivers and a different set of goals
and so software engineering can very
quickly mushroom into a much bigger
thing where you have things like QA
departments and requirements documents
and all those sorts of things which you
hopefully try and avoid being too
onerous in the data science world so
there's this friction between where our
starting point which is the data science
and then software engineering which is
kind of the IT and bit the business and
so in terms of tackling things head-on
which is obviously what we're kind of
aiming to do these are and this was just
my really quick thoughts and there might
be different things in your environments
but these are some of the things that as
a data scientist you might be pushed
into understanding in order to get stuff
into production
I want to kind of just have a little
sidebar on that though in that I don't
think every data scientist wants to
learn this stuff and I don't think every
data scientist should have to learn
this stuff um there are a group of data
scientists who already know this stuff
or who are you know excited by these
things and but also it's about building
bridges with the IT team and getting
them to kind of meet you halfway in
these kind of areas so you might find
that you've got a particularly
restrictive IT team who don't want you
to run new things in production people
are always concerned about new things
they might break the old things they
might cause problems and there are QA
teams that have to be satisfied you know
who's going to write the test scripts
and things like that that you might need
to take an application from your desktop
to a production environment there are
there's automated testing Joe did a
great talk this morning obviously inche
included shiny low tests and shiny tests
which are great ways to test and shiny
applications but I can pretty much
guarantee that your internal IT team if
you have one won't be familiar with
those tools so we need to build those
kind of bridges and staging servers
integration environments continuous
integration continuous delivery these
are all concepts sort of that come from
that software engineering world rather
than from data science but there are all
the sorts of things that people need to
kind of take on board and not
necessarily do themselves like I say I
don't genuinely don't think that all
data scientists should also be software
engineers in terms of getting things to
production but these are the sorts of
things that you'll encounter you know
there I worked on a project a little
while ago and my laptop's company I
worked on a project a little while ago
for a business that wanted to adopt our
studio konnekt so that they could deploy
shiney applications and things like that
and I talked to them initially about how
they might go about doing that they
didn't have any Linux knowledge in-house
connect only runs on Linux they didn't
have any kind of our administration
knowledge in-house so they didn't know
how they were going to work things like
crowd
stuff like that and I had a meeting with
their security board they had a board
that met every two weeks to discuss any
new projects that were coming through
from kind of a security perspective and
I said to them oh yeah you know it's
it's a programming language like any
other there's not really anything to get
excited about and by the way Kranz got
thirteen thousand packages on it and
they were like no it's not gonna happen
so unfortunately for this customer this
is slightly before last year's package
manager came out so I ended up building
them an internal cran to get round this
very strict requirement that they've got
of not bringing 13,000 packages of I
don't say unchecked code but you know
what I mean it's it's kind of community
contributed code into their business so
there are a lot of these kind of
barriers that that will need to be often
overcome in these sorts of organizations
my background is actually more on that
kind of engineering side I was an
infrastructure support engineer for many
years and my role now is basically to
try and bridge that gap so I get into
conversations about doing things like
well we'd like an hour studio konnekt
deployment in our business and that's
great I can do that in a you know half
an hour maybe an hour if it's a
complicated installment installation and
but then people want all help around
that you know I can install the tools
really really quickly but most of what I
do is actually hearts and minds you know
I write documentation for the Linux team
so the Linux team know how to support
our how to you know compile it from
source and where it should be put on the
systems and things like that so it can
very quickly mushroom into a thing
that's got almost nothing to do with
data science at all even though it's got
everything to do with our and production
is very much a team sport which is why I
talk a lot about building bridges
between these between these different
disparate groups within the organization
and as
said before I don't want every data
scientist to have to learn you know all
of the kind of software engineering back
best practice and I don't think that
there are necessarily many data
scientists who are interested in that
sort of thing um which is why it's
important to build bridges with these
different teams within your organization
but obviously and in those circumstances
it's about building a kind of common
language and sort of trying to
understand a little bit about what they
do so I have put together and again this
list is by no means exhaustive but I've
put together a kind of production
readiness checklist for some of this
stuff so when our goes into production
you need to think about the target
environment what is the target
environment is it Windows is it Linux
which versions and things like that you
also need to think about the release
process can you just take code off your
desktop and shove it onto a production
server probably not so you know a lot of
organizations will have a formal release
process that you'll need to either get
on board with or somehow persuade
somebody to adapt for your for your
specific needs and you'll probably need
a testing strategy so it's you know
worth writing down what that is so that
when whoever it is from the QA team says
well you haven't done any testing you
can say well actually we've done a lot
of testing and our testing strategy is
really good and clear some organizations
have a change management process so a
really good example for this one is
retail businesses who often don't want
to change anything in their
infrastructure over the Christmas period
because they're extremely concerned that
any changes might damage their
infrastructure in some way and so
there'll be a gap to three months
whatever it is we're literally no
changes can be pushed to production at
all and you might need a security review
infrastructure is kind of similar to the
target environment but also covers
things like do you need access to
databases and things like that and what
is your deployment process will there be
an automated processes at a manual
will you push straight from your desktop
is it going to come out of get or
wherever who's going to support your
application if you're taking an our
application into production do you want
the 3 a.m. support core when it falls
over probably not so who's going to do
the support they are the support team
prepared to support this application do
they have the information they need with
a lot of data science projects you do
the project and then you move on to the
next one
but in production we need to think about
maintenance
so who's maintaining this thing when the
initial drop is done you know where's
version 2 going to come from who's gonna
do the bug fixes who signs off on
releases which version of are are you
going to use which packages which
versions what system dependencies there
are a lot of things to think about so
this checklist is kind of a starting
point yours will be different feel free
to you know cop here or take a picture
or whatever and add your own things onto
there but these are the kinds of things
that you need to think about and once
you've done that you can be happy up a
mountain enjoying having are in
production and the last thing I want to
encourage you all to do is if you do
have are in production currently or if
you do manage to successfully get are
into production in your organization and
I really want you to share what you've
done somehow anyway because it helps
lift the rest of the kind of are in
production community up and it's really
good to get these stories out there to
encourage others to do the same and so
that we can learn from each other and
last thing that's me thus my the
company's website the last thing is the
field guide to the our ecosystem it has
been quite useful for people who don't
know are so people with kind of ops and
management backgrounds and things like
it's a very short high-level overview of
to our ecosystem and with that I will
stop talking
[Applause]
thank you Mark
we have time for one question if anybody
has any question that they would like to
pose to mark we've got microphones looks
like we have one right over here an
internal crane for our for a company and
installing and running unvetted code is
kind of a big concern in my organization
where the packages somehow vetted when
you were including them in the
repository or how did that work
they were vetted yes so basically all I
did was take they gave me a list of
these are the 80 packages that we use I
got those packages from cran I got all
the dependencies from cran I ran their
kind of corporate antivirus their
corporate anti-malware
stuff over those packages and then I
built a small repository to host them so
that was enough to get their security
team on board effectively yeah thank you
thanks again Mike
[Music]